um correct me if I'm wrong I looked at
the numbers what percentage of the
democratic voters showed up for that for
that Primary in your home state was 4%
around the right
number yeah dismal anyone who thinks
kamla Harris is way to the White House
is through South Carolina is ridiculous
dismal performance in the Democrat
primary last weekend but more
importantly Sean think about this she's
weak On the Border weak on crime weak on
the economy when I say weak on crime
this is a vice president who raised
money for a bail fund for a person who
was later charged with murder you
remember those days Sean this is a
person who refuses to step a foot on our
Southern border 10 million illegal
immigrants coming in and in New York
City it keeps black and brown kids at
home so they can use those schools to
house the illegal immigrants coming into
the country because kamla Harris refuses
to do her her job weak on the economy
poor kids today have less reasons to be
hopeful because Joe Biden and KLA Harris
took inflation so high that poor folks
cannot afford food energy or gas
unbelievable by the way that that that
tweet of the bail fund some might
actually Define that as Insurrection I'm
just saying uh as a as a side note but
of course the media said most of those
574 riots that killed dozens of
Americans injured thousands of cops
caused billions of property damage they
were mostly peaceful so we got to get
that straight um let me ask you about
ridiculous
ridiculous well by the way do you stand
with Ted Cruz and his comments about
Mitch McConnell where do you stand on
that I wasn't in the room when that when
that those comments were made but I can
tell you this without any question what
America needs to see is a United
Republican party telling the facts as
they are the facts are very simple
Sean the president of the United States
Joe Biden does not need legislative
action to secure our border why do we
know that to be a fact because Donald
Trump secured our border without the
legislative action from the body he did
so by creating policies like remain in
Mexico it precipitously saw the drop in
illegal Crossings what we know is a
president with the guts the will the
intestinal fortitude to secure our
border can get it done we've seen it
done once we need four more years we
were better off under
Trump well that's now the big lie let me
play comments president Trump made in
his interview with Maria bomo uh and
they had to do deal with you let's
listen you know I called Tim Scott this
we because a lot of people like Tim
Scott I called him and I said you're a
much better candidate that for me than
you are for yourself when I watched him
he was fine he was good but he was very
lowkey etc etc I watched him in the last
week defending me and sticking up for me
and fighting for me I said man I said
you're a much better person for me than
you are for yourself cuz for himself he
was low-key for me he's been he's been a
real tiger he's been
incredible obviously you're on Donald
Trump's short list if he gets the
nomination it looks like he is what
would your answer
be well my answer would be yes to
America having four more years of Donald
Trump I don't think any one of us should
make this about me or any other person
who might be the candidate for vice
president but you and I know he
mentioned you by name you and I know you
and I know that means you're on the
short list if he comes to you what do
you
say listen everybody wants to serve
their country and the best way for me to
serve my country right now is to make
sure that Donald Trump gets four more
years we're better off under Trump you
and I both know it let's vote for him
but but let's also get out and campaign
for Donald Trump we cannot afford people
losing hope in the American dream
because Joe Biden gets another four
years with Donald Trump low inflation
low crime we have Law and Order once
again it's a good day for Americans all
right I know you're Inner Circle and I'm
going to talk to the two guys I know
you'd call First that nobody knows who
I'm talking about and I'm going to talk
to them and make sure that they're
prepared to tell you to say yes that's
all I'm saying uh we appreciate you
being with US senator Tim Scott and uh
looking forward to the South Carolina
primary hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else